in this video we'll be explaining
everything a private pilot needs to know
about the attitude indicator and how it
works
just like the heading indicator the
attitude indicator is one of the six
primary flight instruments also known as
the six pack and just like the heading
indicator it's also a gyroscopic
instrument the purpose in the attitude
indicator is to measure the aircraft's
pitch and bank in relation to the
horizon without looking outside because
of this some pilots refer to this
instrument as the artificial horizon and
as you can see it's specially
color-coded for pilots so you can tell
the difference between sky and dirt
now there are a lot of different kinds
of attitude indicators out there but all
of them have some kind of bank index so
you can tell what the bank angle of your
aircraft is when your aircraft is in a
bank or roll the roll pointer or roll
indicator points the exact bank angle
that your aircraft is at
in addition to that this miniature
aircraft shows you the bank angle of
your wings in relation to the horizon
when the roll pointer is centered on the
bank index the aircraft's bank angle is
0 degrees
the first tick mark in both directions
represents 10 degrees of bank
the second tick mark in both directions
represents 20.
the third tick mark in both directions
represent 30 degrees of bank on most
attitude indicators you'll find that
these are just a little bit larger or
bolder
next we have the markings that indicate
45 degrees angle of bank on a lot of
older training aircraft you'll find that
they don't have 45 degree markers you'll
have to use the mark 1 eyeball to
estimate the middle between the 30 and
the 60 degree markers and here are 60
degree markers indicating 60 degrees
angle of bank then these markers on the
horizon let you know you're at 90
degrees of bank couple things i want to
mention here first just because the bank
index shows that your attitude indicator
can reach high bank angles it doesn't
mean that your aircraft can make sure
you check the poh for your bank angle
limit you don't want to over g the
airplane because remember our bank angle
is directly related to our load factor
also just because the airplane is in a
bank doesn't necessarily mean the
aircraft is turning to find that out
you'd either have to look at your turn
coordinator or look outside
now let's take a quick look at how the
attitude indicator indicates pitch to
determine the aircraft's pitch angle in
relation to the horizon we'll want to
take a look right here at this little
center point on the miniature aircraft i
call this the pipper now as you can see
here the pipper is right on the horizon
right now that lets me know that our
pitch angle is at zero degrees then as
you can see here these larger
graduations are showing you every 10
degrees of pitch up or down
then these smaller graduations are
showing you every 5 degrees of pitch
now this miniature aircraft can be
adjusted up or down to accommodate
pilots of different heights and you can
do this by twisting this little knob
left or right and when you do this you
should really be on the ground for this
or if you have to do it in flight you
should be in straight and level flight
now as we mentioned before the attitude
indicator is also a gyroscopic
instrument now sometimes you will find
attitude indicators that use electricity
to spin the gyros inside of these but on
most training aircraft you'll usually
find that these use suction from the
vacuum system to spin the gyro
so because of that just like the heading
indicator if you're not getting good
suction on the vacuum system your
attitude indicator won't work properly
have you ever played with one of these
as a kid if you don't know what this is
this is a toy top that you spin and it
maintains its balance by using the
gyroscopic principles the faster you
spin a top the more resistant it is to
wobbling as this mass spins around the
axis it becomes resistant to outside
forces to the extent that the top is
actually able to maintain its balance on
this sharp point as it rotates
and as i mentioned in the last video
this is called rigidity in space and the
attitude indicator has a similar gyro
inside of it that's spun by the air from
the vacuum system
because of the spinning motion the gyro
rotor becomes rigid in space and wants
to maintain its position
gimbals are then attached to the rotor
axis allowing the aircraft to move
around the stable gyro the gimbals are
then mounted to the inside of the
attitude indicator that way it can still
maintain its position in space then it's
connected to this horizon reference arm
which is connected to the horizon on
your attitude indicator and as the
aircraft rolls in pitches the horizon
line maintains rigidity and space along
with the gyro rotor
now just like the heading indicator the
attitude indicator has a lot of moving
parts inside of it and as we continue
our flight friction between these parts
causes our attitude indicator to be less
accurate we call this precession
but unlike the heading indicator where
the pilot has to align the heading with
the magnetic compass we don't have to do
this on the attitude indicator on most
older training aircraft they have
something called pendulous veins when
the aircraft is in straight level
non-accelerated flight the vacuum system
will periodically reset the horizon line
now something i want to mention about
these attitude indicators is that a lot
of the older ones have pitch and bank
limits before the gauge begins to tumble
on most of these gauges the bank limit
is somewhere from 100 to 110 degrees and
the pitch limit is between 60 and 70
degrees when these limits are exceeded
basically what you'll see is the horizon
line spinning around violently inside of
the attitude indicator and i hope you're
in visual conditions if this happens to
you okay enough of that let's take a
quick look at the vfr day minimum
equipment requirements
and as you look at this list you'll
notice that the attitude indicator isn't
on here but it is required for ifr
flight but that's a lesson for another
day
now if you're lucky enough to fly an
airplane with digital flight instruments
like this one you'll notice that the
attitude indicator is huge on this guy
and probably the biggest difference is
that the horizon line spans the entire
length of the primary flight display
also known as the pfd
and that makes it really easy for the
pilot to distinguish between the sky and
the dirt on these newer systems they
have something called an attitude and
heading reference system also known as
ahers inside of these magical boxes they
use solid-state lasers to sense the
pitch and bank of the airplane this
information is then sent to the primary
flight display so it can be used by the
pilot and because these instruments use
lasers instead of free spinning gyros
they don't tumble welcome to the future
of aviation for those who can afford it
that is before you leave today would you
smash that like button for me and if you
haven't already please consider
subscribing and hitting the bell
notification so you don't miss out on
videos just like this one
well not just like this one but you know
now check out this video right here you
know you want to
see yeah
you